after months of negotiations our contact
finally agrees to show us to one of the
illegal laboratories that are feeding
the UK's growing steroid habits we
stopped outside an anonymous looking
garage in the suburban sprawl
it's also the entry point to the hidden
world of illicit steroid production
inside it looks like a professional
operation but this makeshift lab is far
from sterile and these men and not
chemists what they produce though will
be injected by thousands of mainly young
men hoping to bulk up they agreed to
speak to us on the condition we
disguised their voices markets massive
the fitness industry is growing
they won't see another stuff on the TV
we have almost looked good so we get
busier busier more people more people
want to start their own lab that there
are other knowledge of where to get the
rules of how older so they come to us
we're selling them the product the label
it moves around we've been here for
about 25-30 minutes and in that time
they have made 500 milliliters of
testosterone propionate it's worth about
700 pounds now they describe themselves
as small players in this underground
criminal industry they say there are
hundreds of laboratories around the
country and it is big and growing
business we can vote opportune 15 or 20
15 to 20,000 a double to every month or
three that is a huge business
yep knock so I know people are making
like this for watching jokes what are
people doing fifty thousand there are no
national statistics for the number of
people using anabolic steroids but what
is clear is that more and more young men
are prepared to risk their health to
look good in a society where body
beautiful is increasingly important
Louis Davies and Ben Mannion are both
pumping up their muscles before they go
out on the town they both love the gym
their physiques though are far from
natural I take stories because I want to
be I want to look the better I don't
ever want to feel like I'm second-best I
want to look the best and in terms of
widespread is it's all over or
every single gym has it a lot of people
get like acne inside of that I'm not
really an acne prone person I've had a
bit of guy know but which is where you
have inflammation is like the nipple
which isn't really that big of a deal to
be honest move her I just got rid of
that with some tablets I mean the the
health issue for me right now it's not
really I feel I feel healthy I feel on
top of the world so when I taste those I
feel a lot better than when I'm off the
texture because I reached a point where
fell I couldn't get any any bigger or
stronger lots of guys around me you see
him all the time he's getting bigger and
stronger
he's just a case of that you feel
frustrated and you constantly think what
if
wave wave all the time comes to ask
yourself why they did take him what
happened and tried to take a risk all
the athletes in this gym are getting
stronger through hard work alone here
the message is strictly anti steroids
I wanted the boxing trainer Adrian Bush
says the pressure on many young men to
take anabolics
is greater than ever if it's easier to
getting steroids now I've been told and
he's going to shop and buy a can of coke
you watch a film now I'm telling you and
some factories Kurt Buki they want to
look like that it's just a look assault
it is and they don't understand the
competences of developing on to ruining
their life if not killing them it is
difficult to estimate how many illegal
steroid labs like this there are in the
UK but what's obvious is the underground
nature of the supply chain means users
don't know what they're putting into
their bodies person series live starlets
it's like you know people got allergy
but look at that they feel it bar it
doesn't concern you the people might
take something you've made and it could
damage their body or potentially kill
them
although possessing steroids is legal
producing them with intent to supply can
lead to sentences of up to 14 years in
prison but with so much money involved
there'll always be people willing to
take that risk
Alex Rossy Sky News